[Music]
we're back star talk sports edition
a cosmic queries on the physics of
olympic sports and we've got the one and
only eric goff
author of gold metal physics did i get
the title of that correct derrick
it is gold metal physics you know that's
you need
some need some brains in the middle of
what you're doing with your brawn and
your speed or whatever else
and he's got it plus he's got a black
belt in karate
that put that on your resume on your
business card
okay phd physics black belt and karate
that's all you have to put
and you're good to go your students
don't give you any problem not any
problem
at all so eric can we find you on social
media
um john eric goff is my public facebook
page
um i'm still a little bit of a dinosaur
on the social media front but it's
coming along
okay all right well and the more fans
you get on it the more they'll egg you
on
in that direction so john eric gough uh
facebook excellent
and chuck you're still going to chuck
nice comic thank you yes i am and i did
confirm that yes i do follow you
for a while there i was wanting to
follow this let me let me guess you
started this morning
no it wasn't you could say that right
now
yeah and
uh mr my three left feet on twitter yeah
my three left feet that's
that's it you got it you got it so let's
get back to our
patreon questions uh and who's who's up
next who's
all right okay let's go with the next
patreon question alex well
by just by before you do that it
occurred to me in my background here the
audio
there is a ticker tape parade moving up
broadway um
oh for the essential workers yes yeah
this is central workers
uh first first uh responder works
responders
in celebration of uh coming out of covid
because the city is basically open
now and so it's a ticker tape parade
which is
reserved for heroes heroes and in the
old days politicians but
uh nowadays politicians no one thinks of
them as heroes
right people who put their lives at risk
in the service of others
are still respected and and if you win
the world series
right what's worthy same thing right
it's the same it's the same thing so if
you hear that in the background that's
why
the canyon of heroes the champion of
heroes
essential workers well-deserved right
yes you got it
okay what do you have all right my
question is are there
unique ways that athletes especially
olympic athletes
train their minds not to choke when
literally the whole world
is watching them oh tell us about that
choke factor eric
do you get into that as well well what's
the physics of joking
well i i mean focus is obviously what
you have to do i mean you have to be
able to tune out the
the crowd noise the other events that
might be taking place
the best example i ever saw this was
michael phelps and the death stare
i mean you know getting up to the pool
and
just this i'm going to kill you look on
his face
before he jumped into that pool and
of course whenever you've you've got to
do some kind of pre-con
pre-competition routine you know you're
you're going through
a checklist in your mind and what you're
about to do or you're thinking of other
things
all kinds of relaxation techniques are
going to be available to athletes
in modern training so you know they're
going to have to find what works best
for them whenever they get out onto the
the field there so it's it's have a
death stare that works when you're a
good swimmer
it sure does helps if you're the best in
the world
yeah the best in the world works every
time water
you're going down but wait but so are
are there some sports would you say need
your mental
focus more than others for example
well if i was simone biles and i was
about to hop
up on a balance beam i'd want to make
sure that you know
i'm very focused on where i'm walking
you'd think yeah okay i mean there's a
certain sports neil where there's
pun intended here choke points so golf
is part of the olympics
tennis those those you're serving for
the match you're passing off a product
how is goff
the messenger messenger
first of all i did not know that
secondly i
am pissed off like you can't believe
okay a sport
where you get in the cart and drive
to the next
ladies and gentlemen chuck knight just
blew a gasket
i am i can't believe this maybe the
caddies should be the ones being awarded
the medals
there you go it's like nose yes and no
sport where you actually
where the people who play the sport okay
aside from softball no sport where there
is a significant
portion of the population that plays the
game
so they can drink that's ridiculous
okay chuck all right i'm gonna press the
button chuck blew a gasket
would you want in the equestrian section
of the olympics do you want the horse to
get a medal as well
absolutely i mean listen the riders
should get a medal
but the horse when they win the kentucky
derby they put a laurel leaf of roses
around the horse it's just like thanks a
lot guy one day you'll be
glue but right now we love you
but don't forget when espn did their top
50 athletes of the 20th century
secretariat was 35 on the list
nice okay so go back to the original
question formality i'm sorry
i forgot the original question i'm just
sorry blew a gasket i
forgot about relaxation techniques yeah
and then we got chuck relaxing there for
a minute remember we had dr leah lagos
on
and she had this heart rate variability
biofeedback
controlling breathing and then people
could dial up
or dial down their own inner self
and they could if they got the technique
really quickly
they could control it within about one
single breath
right i can imagine that professor
memories
some anxiety is good right i mean you
want to be on the edge of stress
and you want to be able to feel that
anxiety whenever you're going out to
perform
at that high level as a matter of fact
what you just said
is one of the things that she pointed
out to us is that for some
athletes they want to they don't want to
dial down the excite
the excitability of their brain for
others they do
but it also depends on the task at hand
you want some anxiety and stress and
like that feeling of oh my god well i'm
like you want that to work to feed you
in certain
certain situations yeah so chuck i
always imagine a conversation between a
baseball player
and a golfer right and they don't know
anything about each other's sport
and so the baseball player asks the
golfer
um how fast is the ball moving when you
hit it uh
not at all where is it
it's on the ground between my feet
um are people screaming at you
no no it's total silence
so when you swing is is the ball moving
then
no it's still there the whole time
so just to compare and all how about you
when you hit the ball how fast is the
ball going
90 miles an hour the person who throws
it
do they want you to hit it no they do
everything they can so that i can't hit
it
are people silent no they're making as
much noise as they can
so i have to agree with you chuck golf i
can't
i can't go i can't embrace it and in
your and in your analogy
uh the one thing is like sometimes that
guy throwing the ball
sometimes he just throws it at my head
and i should figure out which one it is
i never know what's happening
so gary what else you have for us all
right apologies if i mispronounce your
name
durov diaz this is interesting this is
interesting way to approach this
how are modern day athletes taking
advantage of latest
breakthroughs in a i and machine
learning to analyze their opponents as
well as in
taking informed decisions about their
own bodies
does the olympic governing body have
some rules regarding
using such an ai to prevent athletes to
gain unfair advantage
ooh i wonder if the olympic committee
the ioc
have got ahead of this and have built in
anything regarding the use of ai
and let me add to that is it possible
that ai would discover a
physics loophole that you had not
considered in
evaluating how someone can perform in a
sport i would
i would count the fosbury flop as a
loophole and ai
might have been in a position to have
discovered that before humans did
interesting yeah i mean i haven't heard
about the ioc
doing anything to ban yet but certainly
one of the things we're going to see at
this olympics i know
intel and the alibaba cloud and all that
they're
they've got these 3d athletic training
that's going to be able to help with
viewership whenever whenever you're
watching this stuff you're going to see
real-time data
speed who's in the lead the distance
traveled
they're going to have these cameras set
up around the various events they're
creating these little
like 3d meshes these are geek monitors i
love it
exactly and they're going to have
outlines of the athletes
and you're going to have biometric data
in real time and this is being used in
training
you can actually acquire this data in
training you can know
like where are you outputting the most
power in a given event you know where
does your power wane
you know where you know where do you
need to pick it up a little bit
athletes have talked about in various
different events how they can move a
slightly different way
a slightly different lean angle and all
this provided by all of this data that's
been acquired
and they can shave a couple of tenths of
a second off of a hundred meter sprint
or do a little bit to gary's point eric
is that unfair
if someone doesn't have access to it and
and if
it is deemed unfair is it any more
unfair than
wealthy countries with modern um i mean
historically
wealthy countries had a clean modern
training facilities this by the way this
was contrasted with
in uh rocky iv right there was drago
with all the scientists around him
performing experiments
yeah exactly we saw that that's right
and there's rocky
you know hauling logs up a snow bank so
um is there some does the olympics think
about
parity in in training i mean personally
i think
whatever you can use to train and and
whatever you know science can help you
provide
ought to be legal now i'm not talking
about
you know performance enhancing right
maybe this
the speedo lzr the racer suit that was
the big thing in 2008 beijing where
you go nasa starts working with speedo
and all sudden you've got like
a way to trap bubbles in there and help
your buoyancy i mean
if you're talking about equipment
advantages that's different but i mean
if we're just talking about
you know i mean people have
nutritionists you know they know what
diet to have they know the best way to
get their carbs up to a certain point
like when they're running the marathon i
mean
all of this is just attacking science in
different ways from nutrition
to strength and endurance to flexibility
to
watching your your balance your form
where you're outputting more energy in a
given event
and and i i see no no problem at all
with technology being able to help
people doing it they're always going to
be advanced i mean
you know money's always you know
sponsorship and all this they're always
going to be able to help some athletes
and then not others
so why not if everybody gets the suit
that has the bubbles in it that keeps
you buoyancy
why not let everybody get the suit
that's kind of how i look at it yeah
if everybody is allowed to use the same
suit that's different
but i mean you know if you're creating
advantages with equipment that's used in
a given event
that other countries don't have i mean
that that's that's a little different i
think
this is the same thing with the the
marathon running shoe with the carbon
fiber plates in it
they have not allowed it into
competition because not it is not
readily available for every
athlete now if we go back to ai
and it it can't obviously help you
in the competition of your event but it
can help you in preparation
but is it available to every athlete no
because if it isn't then you either
decide that it is going to be available
to every athlete or you scrap it
yeah but you can't tell people how to
train and ai it would be more
more of a training um construct than it
would be uh
well no i mean listen the united states
wins the olympics for the most part
medal count
every single olympics because why
we're very rich nation and we allow
people to
we give people the freedom of choice to
pursue
their passion so it's not like the
government is saying
oh you're going to be a track star no
it's somebody
who has come up from the time that
they're a kid
dreaming about being a track star but
then some corporation steps
in and says i'm going to dump a bunch of
money on you
so that you can realize that dream yeah
and and you can start
damage but you can improve things
because i mean look at
1992 with the dream team their first
match was angola
angola had like two gyms in the whole
country where they played basketball and
of course they get demolished
but look where international basketball
has come since we you know started
you know the nba was funneling money
into other parts of the world and stuff
i mean sure the rich countries are
always going to be first and they're
always going to have all the advantages
with training but eventually i think it
helps pull up the other countries too
eventually yeah and also gary the
i mean so if i train at high altitude
because i live at high
altitude yeah you can't say no you have
to train at sea level because everyone
else is now see that's the this is the
discussion i'm not saying one of the
answers but that's
yes you were yes you were i don't
pretend like you didn't vote on that
we got time for like a couple more all
right so questions here um we've
uh woody well i think we've kind of
touched on your question about you know
the advantages
with rich nations and training and
nutrition and how we get it
i have a producer bonus question which i
think
here we go so a producer one of our
producers asked this
yeah and that would be me
if we were to watch one event in the
olympics
it's always who's the fastest human on
the planet
it's the hundred meters and uh so
if somebody eric is going to just to be
clear
just to be clear the 200 meters is run
in faster time than twice the world
record of the hundred meters
so technically the winner of the 200 is
the fastest human just to put it out
there
but we all watch the hundred meters yeah
we always
whether it's better marketing whether
they got a better advertising team i
don't know but it's the hundred meters
plus it's on a straightaway so
it's one camera shot all the way down
okay and so
what speed is an athlete going to need
to break usain bolt's 9.58
seconds well when he when he was in the
2012 olympics i think the olympic record
he said was 963 but
he hit almost 28 miles an hour in the
latter part of that run
so you're talking about getting up to
28 29 miles an hour when flo joe set the
record
you know she was a few miles an hour
joiner yeah florence street owner um
back in 88. so this was a
couple miles an hour slower so we're
talking about 25 26 miles an hour but i
mean
you're definitely you're speeding in a
school zone here i mean you're
definitely
past 25 miles an hour
don't run past the schools you get a
ticket in every state
wouldn't it just be great if they're on
the track and it's like
the police officer at the end of the
track with a radar right hit you with a
gun right
is there is there a speed that human
beings
not i'm not talking about cheetah you
know like 70 miles an hour but is there
a speed
with our physiology that is
our absolute top speed yeah
well right now it's about 28 miles an
hour i mean
in other words we're already there
but but also keep in mind when when
bolts at this record he's six foot five
and if you do a little bio mechanical
scaling
your speed's gonna scale with your
height short things
little short critters they have great
acceleration the bigger animals
they have larger speeds top speeds it
took him
41 steps to set that olympic record the
person who got the silver was johann
blake he was
511 took him five more steps to cross
that finish line
so you know he he had fewer steps that
he had to take
bolt did when he when he made that
hundred meter run and set that record
so there are i mean you talk about
advantages hey the guy's six foot five i
mean that's already an advantage when
you're running a hundred meter sprint
so how tall how tall do we go do we do
we get to a seven foot athlete to
to get that leg length that leverage or
is that just
now gone too far now the problem is
these like a pendulum now you're
swinging a lot of mass
in a given direction and you've got a
lot more air drag too with the the
taller you are
so you know i i think bolt almost hit
kind of an optimum
you know he hit the right size and then
the right strength profile
so we have notes that shikari richardson
is
five foot one is that correct is she the
one on the sprinter
yes she's a sprinter and unfortunately
for this olympics
it's been announced that she will not be
able to oh this is from the marijuana
and yeah
right which is total bs like
everybody's marijuana is pretty much
legal everywhere now
well no but that's not even it it's that
marijuana never made anyone run faster
yes i was about to say that
is about five eight i think and and he's
you know a candidate for the hundred
meter and i mean
so when you watch the hundred meter
watch the shorter
athletes come out of the block faster
they're gonna have the acceleration
advantage
watch the taller athletes pick up the
speed at the end and then it's a race to
see which one had the advantage there
and when you watched that bolt in 2012
when he set the record
one thing about that he was the fastest
coming off the block
so he got both ways there he got him
both ways so there you go that's
indefensible
i got the acceleration and i got the top
speed that ain't fair
bromine's the fastest the fastest at a
100 meters in
2021 right now correct
oh yeah brahma i think has the the top
was it nine
seven seven i think for a hundred meters
yeah would you care that it's the
fastest this year we're talking about
usain bolt for goodness sake no i know
but
this year we're going into olympics and
there's no bolt
yeah no bolt no bulk and that 977 that's
only the seventh fastest speed ever
so i mean you know that's that's pretty
good
uh but eric i don't want you to be the
person who in 50 years people look back
on and said ah
he thought we hit the maximum and now
we're running at a nine flat
right this is what they said about the
four-minute mile and the
two-hour marathon and 27 feet
yeah yeah so do you want to be you want
to retract anything you've said in this
it is i don't think we've hit the the
peak of anything i mean
we're always going to be making these
millimetric you know progressions toward
new records and
microsecond changes and and technology
is helping us get there i mean
technology is definitely helping the
training of the athletes
and you know humans are getting a little
taller so i mean
we'll see what a hundred years from now
looks like or at least
we won't other just a clarification
for the 4x100 relay announced uh
pretty much uh right before this show
um she will not be able to compete
the team announced the runners without
her name
she won't be able to is that she was not
sure in other words she was denied
that's what i mean she's denied so she
has denied competition for that
and uh the team says all you uh
usatf uh athletes are equally aware
of and must adhere to the current
anti-doping code and our credibility as
the national governing body
would be lost if the rules were only
enforced under circum
circumstances so there you have it
uh right so that means many fewer people
will be watching that event
that's really what it means that's at
the end of that day
right right well we got to bring this to
a close let me i
mentioned this before but this was
another occasion to say it again
forgive me i don't remember which
airport i was in but i look at airport
mosaics that are on the floor and i
photograph them a lot of them have
cosmic relevance
a compass rose or a constellation a lot
of them do interestingly
so um one of them was a plaque that said
on such and such a date maybe 2012
uh usain bolt landed at this airport
and then it said and his plane landed
ten minutes later oh that's
awesome
you don't expect that because it's like
it's it's it's mosaic
in a floor right is that in heathrow
you said 2012 so they would have been in
london i don't remember it was it was a
domestic airport so oh okay i have to
look at my notes i took a photo of it
uh but it's it's very cute very cute
good sense of humor
yeah so guys so eric thanks for being
back on star talk
great no this is not the last time we're
going to get you on this so
try to stay in arm's reach gary always
good to have you there dude you've been
a pleasure my friend
all right chuck always a pleasure this
has been star talk sports edition cosmic
queries
special guest eric goff talking about
the physics of sports
in this the olympic season i'm neil
degrass tyson as always
keep looking up
you